[Music]
[Laughter]
right this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app 42 of
congratulations and here we're going
here we're going so I'm Chris D'Elia for
those of you that first-time listeners
and they aren't familiar with mo comedy
and aren't familiar with podcasts and I
will be in well let's see there's still
a few tickets left in San Diego on
Saturday so you can get tickets to see
me at sin in San Diego and there are a
few tickets left in Bethlehem
Pennsylvania and I don't know where
there are tickets left but there I'm
coming to Detroit and many Detroit
Minneapolis Tampa Florida you can just
check out all the things El Paso and
come come see me at a show recent
developments starting out I got a you
guys can text me and it's really me
and a lot of people are asking if it's
really me I have a bunch of people text
to me you could text me at eight one
eight two three nine seven oh eight
seven and it's really me I respond to
you and if you don't believe me check
for yourself
if you want to make it easier on
yourself just go to my Instagram and hit
the text button and it'll go right to my
number and I can see your messages a lot
of people are texting me so it's taking
a bit for me to get through them but
that's really me and you can do it and
you don't have to say is this really you
is this a scam because you can hear my
voice right now it's not a scam and tis
really me so come to see me in San Diego
but yeah it's it's cool it's a more you
know [ __ ] it everyone has your
anyway they can just DM you or [ __ ]
tweet you it's the same [ __ ] as having
your number so [ __ ] it
text me drink it I've been drinking I've
been drinking whoa
girl power you know I've been drinking
I've been drinking wait a minute a girl
said something so um anyway I'm chilling
my babies I did some make updates cuz I
did a army of the Dead the movie army of
the Dead which I think it's coming up
next winter or something like that I
don't know just kind of saying stuff and
so I had to do a bunch of makeup dates
and because of that I wanted to do them
as early as I could and because of that
last weekend I was flying all over
creation I went to Detroit did a show
then came back the next day did his show
in Santa Barbara and then the next day
flew to Florida and did one at FAU
now was that entirely too much traveling
yes was a jet-lagged yes did I even know
where I was when I opened my eyes
whenever I took a catnap no does that
mean that I was a little bit more
depressed than usual yes did I come out
of it not yet will I probably will I too
late and then have to travel again right
when I come out of it yes is that just
the way life goes yes does life still
rip you're goddamn right life still rips
dude you know what I realized
after I started saying life rips that
life really rips I really started
realizing that actually life really rips
I came out with the episode life rips
then came out with the subs subsequently
what's the word
so sequential sequential subsequent
episode
laughs rips again and then that's when I
realized that life cat or a pen dude
people were saying you know what life
does rip and life rips is an attitude my
babies and I can't help it you know
people die cants life still rips life
can rip even on your deathbed dude so
that's it I can't wait till those
hoodies get delivered and I start seeing
everybody in those life rips [ __ ]
hoodies I can't wait to get mine dude
just put it up [ __ ] throw it on over
my head and people just see me promoting
how much life rips I should write a
[ __ ] book dude um anyway was a little
bit sick because I was doing my shows
and traveling all over creation dude you
know what happens you know what happens
too much man look here's the deal man
either make it so I can watch movies no
okay so if I'm gonna plain make it so
there's there's two options you got here
planes don't turn on the back of the TV
headrest until after the plane takes off
or make it so I can watch movies right
when I sit down when I board the plane
and shut the [ __ ] up over the PA okay
there's the amount of things that
[ __ ] flight attendants say when you
board the plane is absolutely asinine is
it all good
no dude you sit down well we have two
guys if we can do a crunch back firm
forward you know you got to put it back
forward because if you know if you don't
do you know you got to make sure it goes
in it on the top of the thing if you
don't get it oh yeah this is that so for
the first and then what we do is you you
got to sit down to the thing move all
the way Tori unfortunately it's a full
flight all right dude I'm trying to
watch spider-man far from home dude do
you do you understand me okay so the
vine so then say all the bull
it well you can get rewards code you get
rewards platypus Ward's codes you can
get rewards if you just sign up for the
wards codes and then in Wi-Fi fly 5pi Fi
and then the wards codes and then make
up or decker flag try and put your seat
back in a flash ow
all right fine I'm trying to watch
spider-man far from hub so then make it
so you say all the [ __ ] and then the
flight takes off and then I could turn
on [ __ ] Pokemon dude the only time
like it you can tell I'm on a flight if
I'm watching Pokemon I turned on Pokemon
dude it's so weird how like flights will
have like the movies that you can choose
and it'll be like a bunch of new
releases and then all of a sudden it'll
be like a rear window why the [ __ ] would
you have rear window on JetBlue what
kind of [ __ ] sin a file is gonna be
like mom yes and my if who the [ __ ]
gonna watch rear window oh yeah so yeah
it's been a while since I've seen that
Hitchcock movie I'd love to see it in
[ __ ] a 4-inch screen dude the only
person who's watching rear window first
of all is watching it in a theater or at
home
nobody would ever watch a movie that a
cinephile would watch in a [ __ ] on
the back of a headrest oh cool oh they
got it to mama tambien Oh watch it in
the back of someone's head oh dude what
the [ __ ]
they've got what's the [ __ ] movie
that they would have oh they've got a
[ __ ] oh dude they've got a Fellini
collection oh well let me watch it on
the back of someone's head Oh they've
gotten Dolce Vita or whatever the [ __ ]
it's called oh dude let me watch it on
the back of Rick's head yeah let me
watch a [ __ ] what's that one that
he'd
Oh Lolita let me watch it WOM eatin
cashews dude like this oh this is the
part where he tries to [ __ ] the 14 year
old and shut the [ __ ] up while I'm
trying to watch it do it and if you want
to have and we're just here to and we're
welcoming you and you're welcome welcome
we just want to welcome you while you
walk into the thing and remember you can
choose to fly wherever you want to
choose to the fact that you chose I
[ __ ] chose you why are you doing
another commercial on the [ __ ] when I'm
already riding the commercial it's so
annoying dude Senayan dude I'm trying to
watch [ __ ] Aquaman [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[Music]
chill man and then they're always the
[ __ ] hunky-dory put your seat belts
on video comes on in the middle of you
know you'll get you just starting to get
into the drop or whatever you're
watching the drop with Tom Hardy and
James Gandolfini and then all of a
sudden it's like hi we know here at
American Airlines you can choose any
flight so what we want to do is make
sure you're the most safety seconds
because that's a safety first
well it's anything now we've got a we've
got an ambiguous and Raja dispersing
buckling up their seatbelts and he's
light-skinned you don't know what race
he is whoops you forgot something here's
somebody here's the lady with a short
haircut handing him a pamphlet on how to
do it Hey look we made it funky there's
twins and it's sitting next to each
other but they're like one each one's
eating pretzels and one's drinking them
are two American Airlines we know no
matter what your race gender or [ __ ]
a how tall you are you can do whatever
you want but we're we're thankful that
you four ways if they fight us anything
don't be here we got a bunch of
different Asian people doing a dance
that take a sheet there's a life vest
and there's a life vest under the thing
make sure to always even though you
already know this make sure to [ __ ]
put it on someone else before make sure
you put on yourself before you put on it
and you put it on yourself first because
if you don't and then you die then the
other person dies anyway that's what
we're secretly saying even though we
don't say a light skinned guy yeah
whoopsie anyway enjoy enjoy [ __ ]
spider-man far from home
farting we're [ __ ] here's the men in
black guys dancing around with some life
vests so annoying dude just LEM watch
Aquaman
how dude it's so pretentious that they
have [ __ ] LED dolce vita in the
[ __ ] thing dude in the movie catalog
you know there's like well you never
know you know maybe this is real and
watch the deer hunter you never know the
people that JetBlue you never know dude
you never know you may want about it
what's deer hunter um so yeah so that's
all I'm saying so I flew you know and
they you know I fly first class
obviously because [ __ ] biz acts and I
got to fly so many and you got to put
the money into while you're comfortable
and so I did the [ __ ] so so I flew
and the thing never works dude the thing
is always like you always trying to hit
the thing it's like when you go hi hey
the things not working oh really let me
give it a then they try the thing you
tried okay well I just did that so now
we got two people doing the same thing
hmm
okay I mean actually let me that's what
they do
and then they go up front and then you
just wait a little bit and then you hit
it and then it does it like you need to
[ __ ] just massage it what's that
what's that song that would so be on the
song and it's gonna be the best day of
my life that would be the song that is
in the [ __ ] thing and it's gonna mean
I am alive dude [ __ ] that song I'm
kidding it's bright it's real good it's
good I just you know I don't know how to
[ __ ] judge music I'm the worst yeah
you don't know that yet well you lost my
leg you don't know that
nevermind scratch that my pants
whoopsie I slipped in tripped in scrap
my scraped my [ __ ] thigh on a nail
you don't know you know what the best
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'll tell you man all right
whatever dude so anyway I flew back and
forth did a show let me just go over
this there because it was ripping did a
show Ford in Detroit somewhere near
Detroit no clue where I was for a
college did the laughs kinda were they
offended when I did my jokes about the
about black people kinda is it okay yes
did I tell him to relax yeah
don't care then went to do a show in
Santa Barbara
was great now was the theater in Santa
Barbara did it look [ __ ] so much like
a theater cinnabar at a certain bar
bored yeah like could it be mistaken for
a church of course every building in
Santa Barbara could be mistaken for a
church Hey yes why don't know every
single building in Santa Barbara can be
a mistaken for a church you can go into
a Verizon Wireless and it looks like
you're gonna be talking to a pub so did
that and then I flew all the way to
[ __ ] FAU and that [ __ ] ripped dude
FAU students oh man you guys ripped I
don't know there were like 3,000 kids
there and they just ripped dude I saw
you with your no dent shirts and your
[ __ ] silhouette tees and it was
awesome you guys were ripping somebody
went up and did 35 minutes before me
then my opener went up and did 20
minutes and then your boy was a little
bit like well it's already been 55
minutes into the show are they tired and
your boy still did 55 minutes and your
boy still kept them entertained you kids
have a good attention span so FAU
good call
man it was fun then I got off stage and
it was just it was fun dude
I love FAU that whole [ __ ] southern
Florida [ __ ] like southern Florida is
too much like the south of Florida like
the tip like Megami that's way too
involved but if you go like an hour or
two up or north as they say I'm no
Magellan but I like to call it up if you
go an hour up that [ __ ] [ __ ] straight
up it's so dope because people are a
little bit assimilated you know what I
mean you go down into Miami
it's like [ __ ] it might as well be a
what do you call it a festival a [ __ ]
EDM festival all the time
cuz guys are so [ __ ] stocky it's so
stocky to be in Miami like to be a
[ __ ] white dude a blonde white dude
in Miami it's so stocky you're stocky
you're whiter than you are tall roll to
the event yeah Johnny hey what's up dude
yeah we in Miami which is trying to get
a [ __ ] [ __ ] shoulders wider not
gonna be happy till I'm my [ __ ]
shoulders are as wide as a bench yeah
[ __ ] this [ __ ] man trying to make my
head look real tiny you know I'm young
in the UN understand so keep walking up
if you're in Miami then you get to real
assimilated [ __ ] what's up with this
[ __ ] dude I've been seeing this thing
around a family Dutch family waiting for
end of time found in secret room k not
secret anymore police discovered a
hidden room at a remote farmhouse in the
Netherlands God how many remote farm
houses are in the Netherlands and how
many of them have a secret room dude
every [ __ ] farmhouse in the
Netherlands is a secret room
a family who spent nine years on a farm
waiting for the end of time quote have
been discovered by police in the
Netherlands after one of them turned up
at a local pub reports say I mean you
know so Netherlandish local pub a man of
fifty eight and six young adults aged 18
to 25 were living at a farm in the
province of Drent yes and Netherlands
ends with an e course as landish of the
family were found after the eldest of
the children ordered beer at a bar in a
near blah
I bought a nearby village of ruin or
walled yeah Sanae the lands Drent and
ruiner walled a another land nobody with
brown hair has ever been there only
blood he then told staff he needed help
broadcaster RTV Drenthe ported a
Netherland
hey need help hey what I mean dude
ordered a beer and then asked for help
hey man you've been in a secret room for
nine years hey did ask for help
immediately
then get [ __ ] liquored up we found
six people living in a small space in
the house which could be locked but
wasn't a basement ah it's roundabout say
it different so Netherland yeah we found
six people living in a small space in
the house which could be locked but
what's the basement hey man guess what
some basement so you go downstairs right
so this is what it is not a basement but
you can go into the main area walk into
the house then you go kind of in the
back area then you there are steps you
travel to downstairs then there's a door
and then inside that door that can be
locked opens up and then it is a room
not a basement do you mean well that's a
basement no it wasn't well what do you
mean it's down it's under the it's under
the house right yes it was right
resolvers basement no it's a room not a
basement okay how is it not a basement
because it's what I'm saying
just just what you have to do is trust
us butters shut the [ __ ] up you're an in
cell the older man has been arrested
natch according to the family he is the
father of the six children say police
got props it was not clear whether they
had been there voluntary
clear to me been held captive police
added police are dumb the eldest son was
not there at the time police told the
BBC local reports described man as a
handyman called Joseph B who was a rich
R&B singer bro use your whole last name
otherwise you're a [ __ ] R&B singer
who was originally from Austria Joseph B
so an R&B singer in the 90s and did one
song with Tupac and that was his biggest
hit his number one hit not a basement OS
so trapped I've never seen anything like
it local mayor Roger DeGroot told
reporters synodal and Roger de Groote he
revealed that some of the family had not
been registered locally and is and also
indicated that the 58 year old was not
the father okay okay the public
broadcaster said that the family had
been living in isolation waiting for the
end of time
semental probs bar owner Chris
Westerbeck sanella lent described how a
man had come in ordered five beers and
drunk them oh hey what's up dude can I
get five beers please well yeah do you
want to order them one at a time it
doesn't matter yeah cool here take one
go go go go go
dude let me get another one look agent
let me get my third beer
oh yeah sure that's fine good yeah could
I get my fourth beer please
yeah sure
good hey I'd really like another beer oh
that's a lot but okay okay so anyway
I've been captured for nine years
and I'm waiting for the end of time in a
secret room not a basement over in a
farmhouse in the Netherlands for the
first beer oh my God look at this bar
owner Chris Westar Bieksa Netherland
described how a man had come in order
five beers and drunk then then I had a
chat with him and he revealed he had run
away and needed help then we called the
police he added he had long hair a dirty
beard wore old clothes and looked
confused
that's literally everybody in the
Netherlands has anybody in the
Netherlands not looked confused or had a
dirty beard and long hair and worn
clothes dude they're still on them [ __ ]
the [ __ ] cross colors you know what I
mean they're still on [ __ ] Union what
was that [ __ ] they're still on
Millers that they were submitted man
we're Miller's outpost oh dude Oh
every [ __ ] fifth person in the
Netherlands where's Miller's outpost
still yeah what I don't see the problem
they have good deals and they are still
everywhere so I got gingka genes from
them and I have a cross colour shirt is
fine for - how postural is good for a
lot of back-to-school stuff their nose
up was killed it on the back-to-school
[ __ ] I literally just found out it was a
chain I thought it was only a [ __ ]
place in locking out of that you go to
for back-to-school [ __ ] anyway he he
said he had never been to school and
hadn't been to the barber for 90 years
hey guy go he said he had brothers and
sisters who lived at the farm he said he
was the oldest and wanted to end the way
they were living okay
officers visit Burma has carried out a
search they discovered a hidden
staircase behind a cupboard in a living
room in a well I mean why are they
[ __ ] so intent on making sure that we
think that this is not a basement
who gives a [ __ ] like what happened in
basements in the Netherlands that
they're like we don't that's like
Germans with the [ __ ] they're not not
liking to talk about World War two no
not a basement no no no no no local
postman said he had never delivered a
letter there it's actually pretty
strange not to come to think about it
Wow oh wow check this out you thought
everything else was Netherland check
this out the local postman said he had
never just wait til the end of this
[ __ ] sentence this is the most [ __ ]
you've ever heard this is the most
Netherlands Netherlands sentence you'll
ever hear in your life and the first 80%
of the sentence isn't even at all any
Netherland [ __ ] that's how Netherland it
is at the end of the sentence check it
out the local postman said he had never
delivered a letter a letter there it's
actually pretty strange now I come to
think about it
he told egg limine Dagbladet igloo mean
dagbladet
one time I saw comment on my podcast he
was like I like his stand-up but this
podcast sucks what the [ __ ] I don't get
it it's not even funny all it is is him
making sounds anyway but Jesus Christ
these names yesterday some reported to
us that they were worried about the
living conditions and people in a house
in Budenholzer Wegg and I mean come on
dude they're just [ __ ] with us at
this point
I get it after years of searching I
found my sister next to RK anyway that's
wild man how many how many years would
it for me I mean how many how long would
it take for me to be in a basement I'm
sorry not a basement Netherlands but for
me to be there too
to where I would be like kay I actually
think maybe not it won't be the end of
time any time soon so let's just go
outside I'm real hungry and I want to
get my [ __ ] haircut maybe four days
no four hours I'll do this at end of
times
yeah dude for real you go downstairs and
then you're like alright actually it's
probably okay
the quality of life isn't worth living
down here in this basement so let's just
go because there's [ __ ] and sucking
to get done okay here we go
it's the most wonderful time of the year
Halloween
remember when planning your costume as a
kid was like the most fun you could have
pre Christmas another you're an adult
Halloween feels less Halloween II right
wellmy undies is bringing back the
childlike joy of picking out the perfect
costume with their spooky prints and
Halloween costume onesies that's right
costumes onesies though they're spooky
soft dude I swear to god they're crazy
spooky soft like designed to be the best
thing you've ever put on your body soft
that's what they are they really feel
amazingly soft like softer than a fluffy
kitten you know I'm saying like software
then softer than kind of anything you
get the idea these are the softest
undies known to man and they're also
available in sizes extra small to 4 XL
so that's kind of the gamut if you're
any smaller or bigger than that you're a
dinosaur or a fairy right little one me
undies has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
you get 15% off and free shipping this
is a no brainer especially because they
have 100% satisfaction guarantee get
your 15% off your first pair free
shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed go to me undies
dot-com / Congrats that's my undies
dot-com / Congrats
uh-huh I don't know about you guys but
for me a game is ten times more exciting
when I'm putting my money on it
sometimes I have a gut feeling about a
matchup and sometimes I'm just being on
my team betting on my team because
they're my team regardless whether
you've been betting for years or you're
ready to play for the first time my
bookie is your best bet this season if
you're the kind of guy who likes to bet
a little to win a lot try a parlay for
instance if you like a couple of the big
favorites this week parlays are perfect
because they let you bet multiple games
together for a much bigger payout so if
you're going to bet this season do the
smart thing and go to my bookie AG
because no one gives you more ways to
win between football season the MLB
playoffs and the start of the NBA and
NHL seasons it's time to get off the
sidelines and get in on the action if
you really want to support your team
this season don't just sit on the
sidelines in my babies get in the game
with my bookie AJ and if you join right
now
my bookie will double your first deposit
use promo code Congrats to activate the
offer that's promo code Congrats visit
my bookie dot AG you play you win you
get paid yeah so text me right because
you can do that now eight one eight two
three nine seven zero eight seven so
text me somebody just texted me come to
Philly my mom wants to make you homemade
pasta okay Tom that's Tom this guy wrote
yo Chris I doubt this is actually you
doubt wow this guy spelled out so [ __ ]
up that I don't remember how to spell
doubt do you ght hey I dot Chris I hey i
chris daughtry this is actually you i'm
gonna just write them back doubt the
right way like a like a dick doubt doubt
you
you be that's doubt but thank you but
thank you I'm writing
yeah I'm texting back baby a lot of
people are doing it already cool sounds
good all right well yeah so anyway text
me I'll be in San Diego mm-hmm
and I want to know dude i checked it by
the way i stayed at the MGM Grand in
Detroit and then now you know in
retrospect I can say it can't say it
beforehand because then you guys will
show up but I stayed at the MGM indeed
ran into Detroit and I was uh I was
checking in and the lady was so nice she
was like hey how you doing and I was
like hey what's up
and she was like so to get to start I
just need your ID and your credit card
now is that cool there you go
and then I was texting I was on my phone
which is annoying as [ __ ] actually I
probably shouldn't have been it's
actually probably a so annoying for
people checking in stuff in doing their
hotel job and you're like texting and
talking to them so she was like all
right here you go you're on the top
floor to get to the top floor 17 what
you got to do is put your put put the
arm hotel card in it take it out and
then and then press the button otherwise
you ain't gonna get to 17th for I was
like all right cool
and she was like all right and then she
was like and I checked in my buddy to
pay for the hotel room and I don't wait
that's the time I could do this checked
in on my buddy paid for the hotel room
and after the fact and then and then I
and then I and then she was like all
right and I was like [ __ ] I'm sorry I'm
texting I'm my bad and she was like it's
okay and then she was like as long as
you paying attention and I was like yeah
I checked in Craig my opener and then I
and then I said okay thanks and she said
she was like so how you get to your
floor and I was like what say tell me
how you get to your floor I was like I
just I put the card in and then I hit
the button and she was like no you take
it out first house it yeah I know how
did [ __ ]
can use an elevator and she was like
well you ain't listening oh man it was
so funny dude I was like yeah I know you
put in you take it out and then you hit
the [ __ ] top floor it's just like
alright well I'm just making sure it
really brought me back to New Jersey
like when I was growing up that's how
people I just love it I love it when
someone can lovingly like rib you like
that you know if you did that in LA
someone would file a lawsuit anyway I
thought it'd be good to stay in the in
the in the casino because of how it
would be everything would be right there
I don't understand people do this I
asked the guy walked down to the thing
and they were checking IDs and I was
like hey is there a Starbucks Starbucks
in there and I go guy goes like this
nope and I'm like hey waiting for you to
still talk because it's still your turn
and he says but there is a Beanery over
there if you want and I was like yeah I
mean dude that's what I'm talking about
you know I'm not like I mean coffee it's
like if you say Kleenex you have a
Kleenex you don't get the peeler like no
we have other tissues though you have a
Starbucks there's a coffee place over
there it's not a Starbucks though the
guy just goes no like acid dick okay I
waited though I stay in the cut dude
when someone's rude I I stay in the I
pick out a magazine I start reading and
I stay in the cut because it's still
your turn to talk you don't make it
awkward for me bro go ahead feel the
rudeness judo baby I'm taking your
momentum and I'm putting it back on you
I'm a black belt in conversational judo
that's it so he goes nope and I lay in
the cod tick-tock [ __ ] and then
he says but there's a Beanery oh [ __ ]
conversational judo dude we've been over
this when somebody says you don't
remember my name
ha I [ __ ] move closer and I keep
holding your hand while shakin and I say
nope did it on set of army the dead you
don't remember my name huh a weekend and
I said nah and she says well it's this I
don't want to you know expose her but
she was like well it says I said alright
cool now I know she's like well I
already told you alright so I'm the dick
I guess uh yeah I don't know but uh
we're gonna say I'm on my fourth set of
ear pods by the way dude here's the deal
Oh make them square so they don't
[ __ ] fall out of your sideways
pockets this [ __ ] is they have I swear
to god they have oil they're so glassy
I've got my fourth [ __ ] pair they
make them scion dynamic there's no
reason to make the [ __ ] case
aerodynamic they're in my pocket okay
they're gonna be slipping out they want
you to drop them this is a conspiracy
for real Apple wants you to drop them so
you buy another pair there's I know all
your [ __ ] is curvy and all that but stop
with the curvy [ __ ] make the air pods
square you take them out you know you
take them out they're still curvy you
take out the [ __ ] things they're
curvy the little buds are curvy
everything is curvy dude I've dropped
them so many times and I got a how about
when you drop something how far it goes
today I'm talking about it's never right
there on your goddamn foot that's where
I dropped it dude you drop something
this [ __ ] is in [ __ ] Taiwan always
man you drop something in the car check
the trunk if you're driving you drop
something in the car check the trunk
it's never there it's always in the
backseat if you drop air pods prepare to
walk get your [ __ ] walking shoes on
dude
it's so annoying how far it [ __ ] you
drop your ear pods dude be prepared it's
so annoying dude
whoops drop somebody drop my ear pods
[Music]
these boots are made for walkin
that's just what they all ooh these
boots are made for walkin I love her use
it didn't try with it and that's just
what they'll do part just wanted it to
rhyme at the end hey try harder
but both song this song such a hit
though it's got a hundred and
thirty-four million views on [ __ ]
YouTube is but some and fork in the law
man look I'm gonna do music you know how
it used to be we all live in a yellow
submarine okay that's crazy that that
was a song that is absolutely crazy that
that's a song and now this is a song
dude crazy that we all live in a yellow
submarine was a song and now this is a
[Music]
alright wow dude to change dresses like
a [ __ ] two-year-old on Halloween like
a full leopard-print thing and like some
really really big shoes like that's what
a [ __ ] daughter would wear that came
out three years ago um anyway yeah but
these earplugs are pissing me off I'm
done talking about ear pods dude I'm
still
I try to read I'm reading the book it
I'm trying it cuz I like I like to see
where they where it came from because I
like to read the I like to read the [ __ ]
if the movie gets popular and I'm like
[ __ ] 100 pages in I don't even know I
don't know dude I'm such an idiot man
you try reading books and [ __ ] it's just
like what if you dip out for one
paragraph and just start thinking about
sex you're like you got you you're
[ __ ] you got to go back like three
pages I'm hot like both sweaty and
[ __ ] sexiest [ __ ] support for
congratulations comes from manscaped who
is number one in men's below the belt
looming manscaped offers
precision-engineered tools for your
family jewels man i can't tell you how
many time i times i nicked my balls
sometimes i i've done it and and then i
the balls get to bleedin and then you're
like k guess nobody's gonna be seeing my
balls for the next few weeks but this
takes that out of that that's why
manscaped has redesigned the electric
trimmer their lawn mower 2.0 has
proprietary skin-safe technology so this
trimmer won't Nick or snag your nuts
manscaping accidents are finally there a
thing of the past and don't use the same
trim around your face as your balls
because that's weird I mean you know
you're gonna be doing the the shaving
thing and then also your balls and then
your friend comes over and he's like oh
[ __ ] that's your beard trimmer but
really you use it for your balls I don't
want any mix-up manscape also has the
crop preserver or anti chafing ball
deodorant and more moisturizer dude your
balls smell okay so your armpit smell
you put stuff on your armpits so put it
on your balls to manscape got a got you
covered get 20% off free shipping with
code congrats at manscape com get 20%
off free shipping and a free travel bag
with the code congrats at manscaped comm
that's 20% off with free shipping and a
free travel bag at manscape calm and use
code congrats Skillshare you heard of
this skill share is an online learning
community with thousands of amazing
classes covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills you can take
classes in everything from
free and creative writing to design
productivity and more so whether you're
returning to a longtime passion project
challenging yourself to get outside your
comfort zone or simply exploring
something new Skillshare has classes for
you say they sent us a bunch of course
courses to check out and I I checked out
the entrepreneurial the Entrepreneurship
section they have and you know you boys
a businessman so your boy had to check
that out so I watched this one called
entrepreneurship hustle from business
plan to real success and now dude now
look at me okay
since then I watched this and now look
at me and we join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's right skills share is
offering congratulations listeners two
months of unlimited access to thousands
of classes for free
okay so sign up and to do that you go to
Skillshare dot-com / congrats go to
Skillshare dot-com / congrats to start
your two months now that skill shared
calm / Congrats come on dude don't
remain dummies get cultured
congratulations is brought to you by the
Cash Shop the official app of the log
cabin any book Tom a poem walkin nosey
anyway uh text me again you could text
me at eight one eight two three nine
seven zero eight seven that's what's up
my baby's gotta get all your messages
see ya
what else we doing we takin over dude
I'm a good singer man I should practice
more cuz then I could [ __ ] give Josh
Groban a run for his money you raise me
up higher than a mountain you raise me
up Oh [ __ ] so high
yeah you're my dad or whatever that song
is about anyway do we have what do you
call it anything like things okay let's
do some questions bro we haven't done
this in a while let's do some questions
Oh interesting on episode 36 is by Wade
not 9 8 1 0 on episode 36 you answered a
Twitter question about wearing
sunglasses indoors and said it was
terrible did you change your mind or did
your future just get so bright that it
became a health hazard and you had to so
I understand mm futures too bright
future so bright so ya wear sunglasses
indoors cuz I'm a future but here's the
deal man you can kind of do anything as
long as your attitude is like [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you know I'm saying like I was
thinking about this the other day if you
wear Tevas or Birkenstocks or Doc
Martens like my point is if you wear
some real corny [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay and if you're wearing it because
you're not thinking about what you're
wearing and you're just like oh someone
gave me those or I'll wear them or okay
cool I'll put them on because they're
convenient or they're comfortable then
you're a [ __ ] dork but if you legit
think whoa TVs are the [ __ ] and you're
like I know they're not in fashion but
[ __ ] y'all because I think they're the
[ __ ] then more power to you most guys
who wear sunglasses at night or indoors
they're wearing them because they're
insecure and they want to show you how
cool they are but if you actually are
like [ __ ] y'all I'm gonna wear these
indoors because I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] then dude that's some
serious jeremy renner [ __ ]
if your word a long coat in the desert
just because someone made you think it's
a good idea then straight up but if
you're wearing it because you think long
coats are the [ __ ] and short coats can
go suck dicks then honestly so there's
no mind changing babies now that doesn't
mean that that it doesn't change his
mind daddy changes his mind cuz changing
your mind is all about growth and the
world changes so you have to when people
are like [ __ ] change that's crazy to me
for life to continue to rip you have to
keep changing we grow every cell in your
body wasn't in your body about ten years
ago they're all new cells and I think
that that's true probably because Neal
Brennan told me so anyway yeah
that's some real [ __ ] is there another
question thanks for your question Wade
nine eight one zero Austin burns at
Austin Dolphins Christa Lea thoughts on
fantasy football I mean sir wants me to
[ __ ] be favorable about it cuz his
name is dolphins in it bro my brother
does fantasy baseball and [ __ ] and look
let we know obviously there is
absolutely nothing dorkier than fantasy
football everybody knows it's all good
and it's fine and it's fine it's all
good now is fanciful perky yes is it all
good yeah don't do fantasy football and
think it's not dorky yeah you know I'm a
[ __ ] dork if you're doing fantasy
football you're basically the guy saying
well I just think it's interesting
because the original the original comics
that Wolverine had it he had a different
outfit on and whatever if they're gonna
update it fine but still stick true to
the thing but they're not really doing
that and that's fine basically that's
what you're doing if you're like oh ho
[ __ ] dude
Tim salmon is [ __ ] got some [ __ ] so
now I'm [ __ ] my my [ __ ] is my [ __ ]
teams on top because Tim salmon you're
you're basically saying look I just
think it's funny that the juggernaut you
know could go through walls and
it's like obviously he could be stopped
but nightcrawler all he needs to do is
take care of business and he's not doing
that there's basically what you're doing
is you're saying oh yeah I just think
it's funny the [ __ ] you know todd
zeile todd zeile obviously [ __ ] he
could do a little bit better but he's
not because because of the injury and it
sucks because he's on mum
he's on my [ __ ] fantasy team no no no
oh yeah Todd seals on my fantasy team no
he's not dude
Todd seals on the Cardinals and that's
it now do i new new players no isn't
Molina a player the shortstop guy Molina
is killing it cuz he's um he's been
shortstop I'm afraid he's on my fantasy
team no he's not he's only on st. Louis
he's only on the Cardinals Molina is not
on your team you know why cuz Molina is
not on your team number one and million
is on st. Louis number two and number
three you don't have team hey dark
it's a fantasy football take a hike my
brother will go like bro ma my fantasy
teams killing it and I go yeah that
doesn't [ __ ] matter any laughs
because he knows dork
you know what how about the dorkiest
[ __ ] about the fit of the fantasy
football are the names that people use
for their [ __ ] teams it's like that's
the only thing worse than band names
like Sparklehorse you know yeah what is
this [ __ ] people say do you have people
come at me they say oh you don't have
we're the first this hit hey Chris Lee
are you holding the the first 41
episodes of congrats pod hostage how
much supposed to be true leave if I
don't access to all the baby things dude
it they're up there look for them
they're all available bro use Google
what am I your [ __ ] grandma a Google
anyway dude what else any other
questions one fire says this one's funny
so if it's not
congratulations pot this is by Juke c24
baby squirrel okay obviously you know
what's coming
change it
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh wow okay stage coat new lineup again
didn't they just [ __ ] do stagecoach I
saw every two weeks there's a new line
of a [ __ ] stagecoach okay let's sit
click on it and now get the stage coat
you know what pisses me off the
stagecoach font it looks like some old
lady [ __ ] that font that they use is
some is the font the stagecoach font
that they use the official stagecoach
font that they always see the word
stagecoach in is so the font that a
store would use that my mom would walk
by and [ __ ] window shop that all
right like what did I like the does you
see that that you should get that for
you should get that for your girlfriend
that's what my mom would do you should
get that you should get that for you
should get that for your aunt right
there she likes those kinds of things
and christmas is coming up these are the
people california's country music's dude
every two weeks his stage is every two
weeks i already did this but I guess
it's funny Thomas Rhett Brett Young
Dustin Lynch III do I can't believe
these people's [ __ ] names man I mean
as as Netherlandish as the Netherland
ish names are the stagecoach names are
the stagecoach names I mean the guys got
their name is Eric Church sir religious
Eric Church Tim pew and Josh [ __ ]
pastor and [ __ ] Brian Lord lover and
Tim hanging on cross Tim hanging on
cross hey what's up I'm Tim hanging on
cross come on down to stagecoach we're
we guarantee we use the font that
Chris's mom will [ __ ] stop it short
store and window shop Thomas Rhett Brett
young Dustin come on down a stagecoach
where everyone's way to what why come on
Stan it come on down it's a stagecoach
where everyone's name is to do it why
all right we got Thomas Rhett here in
the house Brett young Dustin Lynch Billy
Ray Cyrus Morgan wiling little Nozick's
the only guy who doesn't have a little
white name it's the only guy who's not
what we'll buy anyway we got Mitchell
Tenpenny Nicky Lane of course rail in
one word of course Hardy of course Pam
Tillis
Ingrid Andrus the last bandoleros which
is somehow [ __ ] white or even though
it sounds Mexican say bar then then we
have with the Jones and Whitney Rose I
can't believe these names dude Carrie
Underwood course dan + Shay Midland ZZ
top low cash Teddy Ross courtney marie
andrews take Peyton Smith the guys in
the littlest font are the best I mean
dude the Haden triplets oh my [ __ ] the
Haden triplets dude so white the whitest
[ __ ] I first of all it's so white to be
triplets shouldn't I mean like if you
have [ __ ] two more you next to you
that's the whitest [ __ ] ever Wow Wow
I don't know what else to [ __ ] even
say about that how about the [ __ ] that
do you see the picture I gotta tweet
this picture why are there so many
pictures of Vladimir Putin chillin so
hard you googled Vladimir Putin you'll
see him just like on a rock looking like
it's his library
dude he couldn't be sitting more like
he's in libraries and he everywhere he
goes he's chillin even when he's sitting
on a horse he's just literally has a
look of like I have a library at my
house
these pictures are unreal um what else
do we got pictures no of uh from you
questions that's it do we have a no miss
connections or whatever whatever bro
it's all good let me look at my [ __ ]
texts and see who's got what let me see
who's texting me
oh my [ __ ] thing here guy writes hey
can I send you a shirt and a beanie man
I don't know I'm writing I don't really
like beanies that much that much and
every time
I'm texting this guy back time someone
sends me a shirt it seems like it would
fit only a child I got to keep it real
man there you go Aidan just texted you
back do it I got to keep it real I can't
I can't front there's this weird thing
that's going on in comedy and it's like
it's this thing where like people wanna
like the because the left is being so
pusseh fied that these comedians want to
[ __ ] quote-unquote tell it like it is
and that's becoming really increasingly
annoying like any reaction to something
that's so drastic is also annoying so
like there's this thing where it's like
some some comedians
really good at it like Bill burr Chris
Rock Dave Chappelle they do the telling
it like it is at the it meets the
funniness but some comedians are like
bro I just got to keep it real and tell
it like it is and they do it so hard
that they're not being funny as well
like that should never be the forefront
I've been thinking about this man so
many comedians are trying to tell it
like it is that it isn't being funny and
then there's enough people in the world
that will like you no matter what if you
have some sort of fan base because
there's [ __ ] 7 billion people out
there that some people will just be like
a man props to you for keeping it real
no not props to that person for keeping
it real stop keeping it real be funny I
don't want to keep it real even though
you know daddy's got to keep it real
because it's a comedy but really be
funny that's why I always say we're down
for a silly goose time in that set man I
don't want you to mistake me for one of
those [ __ ] that's always
telling it like it is bro keep in mind
always underlying [ __ ] you [ __ ] but
also on stage
silly goose time [ __ ] you gotta mix the
[ __ ] with the because if you just
have that then you won't have enough but
what we're really looking for is you
know what I'm saying does it make sense
for hearing it for a hearing aid for an
audio aid is that make sense to you it's
not enough to just keep
but we'll be funny and that's all I have
to say about that and I still can't
believe that [ __ ] six people were in
the Netherlands and a basement for nine
years and the seal I think I've been
thinking about ever since I've been
talking about it this podcast and it's
all good but dude let me also say
something else to you guys I want to
thank you for listening to this every
week and being and supporting me and
coming out to the shows it's just
[ __ ] awesome and it's really cool to
be able to share this podcast with you
and it's also really cool too
what do you call it be able to do what I
do and I'm glad I get to make you laugh
and I mean that man
so look download the cash app for free
on the App Store or Google Google Play
market and you could text me at the
number I told you go to my Instagram and
just click the text button and you get
to get the merch at Chris D'Elia calm
subscribe to the YouTube channel rate
review the show and tweet me by using
the hand between me whatever video
podcast go up a day after the audio
podcast and very cool anyway thanks for
coming to see me
San Diego I'll be there in a little bit
and you guys are awesome
thanks guys I'll talk to you later
[Music]